[Music]
gripped with vengeful passion the queen
of the night tears across the stage she
begins to sing her titular aria one of
the most famous sections from Mozart's
beloved opera The Magic Flute the
orchestra fills the hall with music but
the Queen's voice soars above the
instruments its melody rings out across
thousands of patrons reaching seats 40
metres away all without any assistance
from a microphone how is it possible
that this single voice can be heard so
clearly above the strains of dozens of
instruments the answer lies in the
physics of the human voice and the
carefully honed technique of an expert
opera singer all the music in this Opera
House originates from the vibrations
created by instruments whether it's the
strings of a violin or the vocal folds
of a performer these vibrations send
waves into the air which our brains
interpret as sound the frequency of
these vibrations specifically the number
of waves per second is how our brains
determine the pitch of a single note but
in fact every note we hear is actually a
combination of multiple vibrations
imagine a guitar string vibrating at its
lowest frequency this is called the
fundamental and this low pitch is what
our ears mostly use to identify a note
but this lowest vibration triggers
additional frequencies called overtones
which layer on top of the fundamental
these overtones break down into specific
frequencies called harmonics or partials
and manipulating them is how opera
singers work their magic
every note has a set of frequencies that
comprise its harmonics series the first
partial vibrates at twice the frequency
of the fundamental the next partial is
three times the fundamentals frequency
and so on virtually all acoustic
instruments produce harmonic series but
each instruments shape and material
changes the balance of its harmonics for
example a flute emphasizes the first few
partials
but in a clarinets lowest register the
odd-numbered partials resonate most
strongly the strength of various
partials is part of what gives each
instrument its unique sonic signature it
also effects an instruments ability to
stand out in a crowd because our ears
are more strongly attuned to some
frequencies than others this is the key
to an opera singers power of projection
an operatic soprano the highest of the
for standard voice parts can produce
notes with fundamental frequencies
ranging from 250 to 1500 vibrations per
second human ears are most sensitive to
frequencies between 2,000 and 5,000
vibrations per second so if the singer
can bring out the partials in this range
she can target a sensory sweet spot
where she's most likely to be heard
higher partials are also advantageous
because there's less competition from
the orchestra whose overtones are weaker
at those frequencies the result of
emphasizing these partials is a
distinctive ringing Tambor called a
singers squeal Oh
opera singers work for decades to create
their squeal oh they can produce higher
frequencies by modifying the shape and
tension in their vocal folds and vocal
tract and by shifting the position of
their tongues and lips they accentuate
some overtones while dampening others
singers also increase their range of
partials with vibrato a musical effect
in which a note slightly oscillates in
pitch this creates a fuller sound that
rings out over the instruments comprar
Tavares once they have the right
partials they employ other techniques to
boost their volume singers expand their
lung capacity and perfect their posture
for consistent controlled airflow the
concert hall helps as well with rigid
surfaces that reflect sound waves
towards the audience all singers take
advantage of the
but different vocal signatures demand
different physical preparation a vog
nari and singer needs to build up
stamina to power through the composers
for our epics while Bel Canto singers
require versatile vocal folds to vault
through acrobatic arias biology also
sets some limits not every technique is
feasible for every set of muscles and
voices change as singers age but whether
in an opera hall or a shower stall these
techniques can turn unamplified voices
into thundering musical masterpieces
guitar masters are capable of bending
the physics of sound waves to their
wills plucking melody from inspiration
and vibration check out this video to
learn more about the physics of the
guitar
[Music]